amid draconian shutdown orders a number
of silicon valley companies as we were
just saying
uh hp oracle tesla are leaving
the bay area for texas for years
politicians have assumed that
unrelenting growth
is a good strategy but could having more
californians
back fire on texas governor greg abbott
joined tucker to talk about it
governor thanks so much for coming on
first congratulations
such an obvious success story people are
leaving california they can go to 49
other places they're coming to your
state
that is an endorsement of the way you're
running it obviously
so sincere congratulations but i do have
a question we've seen
this across the country where people
flee a collapsing
crummy state and then wreck the state
they go to
are you worried totally sincere question
that all these californians will bring
their values
and degrade the state of texas
tucker this is the number one question i
get from fellow texans all the time when
they see all of these headquarters
relocate from california to texas and i
have
great news for them and that is these
relocations
are not going to change the politics in
texas
and we have mathematical proof for it
two years ago i was on the ballot at the
same time that ted cruz and beto
o'rourke were on the ballot
we did an exit poll asking people after
they left the polls
did you vote for ted cruz or did you
vote for beto or wart
and then we asked him have you moved
from california or your native born
texan
the results of that poll showed that 58
percent of the people who moved from
california
voted for ted cruz interestingly that
almost identically matches
a separate poll that was taken also an
exit poll from that same election
that showed that 57 percent of the
people who moved from california
voted for ted cruz and both of those
polls
match a study that was done a couple of
years before that that asked
californians that came to texas
are you conservative or are you liberal
57 percent of the people who moved from
california
said they were conservative 27 percent
of the people who moved
from california said they were liberal
and there are reasons
for this tucker and that is that if
people
like big government if they like high
taxes if they like
more regulations they're going to stay
in california and the last place they
would come to
is the state of texas but tucker i need
to add this
because i talk to ceos every single week
and i listen to their concerns whether
they're coming from california or
new york or some other state and they've
added a new reason
this year why they're coming to the
state of texas and leaving these other
states
and that is because of the lack of
policing
in these other states you see these
movements
to ban police or defund police whatever
they want to call it
in texas we're talking about defending
police
not defunding not defunding police we
will support law enforcement in texas
you know businesses may i interrupt you
better interrupt you because i think you
make really strong points those are
clearly true but there's another factor
that's never considered
texas is a great place in park because
it's a very religious state no one ever
says that but you go to dallas and
you know people are doing bible study at
starbucks
the truth is there are massive cultural
differences you're getting
a lot of people with left-wing social
values moving into your state they've
already completely wrecked austin as you
well know
you're not concerned about that i'm not
again in part because of the studies and
also in part because of the
thousands of californians that i have
personally
dealt with that have come to the state
of texas it's the californians that
they they believe in god they believe in
guns and they are so excited about
coming to the state of texas
and and getting a gun that they couldn't
have in california and so
it's the people who want to re-engage
with their faith the people who want to
have
guns are the people who believe in
fossil fuel
and they're trying to get away from the
hostile positions of california against
all of those issues and so there is a
reason why they're coming here
but also remember this tucker there are
some people who are actually
leaving texas and going to california so
we we have kind of a trade deal going
here
the liberals are leaving texas and the
conservatives are coming from california
to texas
i hope that's true i should say in the
interest of full disclosure i am from
california
i'd be very wary of letting people like
me in
but good luck we're certainly if texas
goes then we're done so
please uh keep an eye on that governor
great to see you tonight thank you
thank you tucker